thank you
[Music]
so you guys know how much we love
watching movies and [ __ ] yup is that
Bart yeah we're talking about I love
movies what's the last movie you saw
um what's the new one
mask the mask the Jim Carrey I've been
watching it with Tycoon Cameron Diaz was
like 19 The Mask
what's the most recent one and taika's
been watching The Masks which one oh
with Eric Stoltz yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah dude when I was a kid I just
always be like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
the mask is on I click the mask and I'm
like that's not the mask that's not Jim
Carrey bro I was like was his name Rocky
in the movie his name was Rocky
something was it yeah
I watched that movie it's a good movie
it actually is I thought it was good
maybe you guys remember the the sequel
to The Mask but it didn't start Jim
Carrey Son of the Mask yeah that was
funny well there's two there's some of
the mask and then there's like the dog
one right he's a dog yeah that was good
is that like air blood but the mask yeah
you [ __ ] see this one watch that one
don't be excited about it
I would throw that on in the background
of a party yo you'd have to get people
to get more social Air Bud like 50. no
yeah all right have you have you guys
seen Neil Breen films Neil bring why is
that something oh my [ __ ] god what
are we missing out or are we oh wait
damn first we can't keep this 30 seconds
okay so no Neil Breen is this guy who's
like a self-made director actor producer
star and he makes his own movies okay
and he did one called double down and
it's him as an action star but it sucks
and he thinks he looks tight in it
though it's not the guy who goes oh hi
Mom
did you show us him at Playlist Live I
guarantee I have I guarantee you the guy
where he's like he just like
like everyone's just flying and just
like but he but he's like like beating
people like this and then people just
flying like that no no he doesn't have
enough production for that that sounds
brilliant already mule Breen the one
that you showed me this guy wasn't even
trying and it looked like he had
arthritis everywhere and he was whooping
everyone's ass no you know what he is so
he's so litigious I can't show this
because he'll have her video taken down
yeah I know I remember this he is so
little after I'll show you guys on live
after two okay so the FBI says that
these two criminal Guys these burglar
guys they wanted to burgle a cash
register but as every smart criminal in
the movies do what do you do first
look if there's cameras clothes you
spray paint them no
what do you do first if you're
burglarizing a cash like uh if you're
gonna if you're gonna burglarize a joint
and you're watching them yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's gone sure and then you're
gonna take hostage and you're gonna cut
the power you're gonna cut the power cut
the power so these two guys cut the
water took out the entire electric grid
in Washington
yeah just the whole state just to well
in this part of Washington
um just to just to Rob like a cash
register a cash register yeah just a
robot cat so they're trying to do some
Bank level high [ __ ] but for like 200
bucks GTA prep Mission they saw Ocean's
Eleven exactly right that's a really
good night that's what they did Notions
11. remember they took out the whole
city Grid in Las Vegas yeah but that was
like Millions yeah trying to steal a lot
of money there like 150 million how much
you think what do you think how much do
you think they took out of the cash
register 35 bucks um it it actually
doesn't say well it depends if it was
the end of the day it wants to see a
picture of the capture
it would definitely make more money
that's so good if they were contracted
to do just that task alone from another
burglar watch they show up and they're
like oh my God it's a cashless store oh
yeah oh no it's a card only not a
Chinese restaurant [ __ ] due to the coin
shortage we don't accept captions it's a
24-hour fitness oh true oh no so these
steal all the bag energy these Geniuses
ended up taking out the power grid
um on CR on Christmas and left thousands
of people in the dark and cold Christmas
and put some okay that's kind of funny
for medical devices
you should resign so funny you should
reside right now disgrace recuse
yourself
I didn't say that was funny dude roll
away roll away I'm out dude still alive
go apologize for the life it's not
generators and [ __ ] hospitals got
generators and [ __ ] okay you're still in
my [ __ ] blaming victim blaming
yeah those are generators recuse
yourself from Kaiser so the hospital
didn't turn on the they go back well and
then the breathing machine goes
people at home people at home in medical
places right look dude Tesla batteries
for their house
[Laughter]
I was having such a good time
um so yeah the Department of Homeland
Security has previously warned that
power infrastructure is an attractive
Target for domestic terrorists so this
is showing like another vulnerability
even that's an upgrade for these guys
like title wise domestic terrorists well
no they're saying that they're a target
for domestic terrorists like the power
grid is yeah but these two cats they
don't see any motivations but like
terroristic motivations no they don't
necessarily cash registers they don't
level up as criminals because of this to
uh terrorism though obviously
man I just can't believe it's that easy
to turn off like that's what I'm saying
it's so sick though it's like kill power
kill power where would you go like if I
want to do that in our city say in
Monterey Park like where DWP maybe yeah
go to DWP Monterey Park is it that
accessible probably maybe go to City
Hall look around yeah just ask Mitchell
yeah I'm looking to cut off some power
dude because I watched too many movies I
think I would try to Die Hard it where
he like you know how he takes a chainsaw
and he cuts all that [ __ ] but I'm like I
probably electrocute myself yeah for
sure yeah
because I also like Cat5 cable it would
be like it there would be like an arc
beam just like shooting out you just
need like rubber gloves and then it
stops that's really good all right and
rubber shoes yeah yeah and then you're
good it can still burn the [ __ ] out of
you not with rubber it stops rubber no
it could still burn through rubber I
don't want to argue with you two pairs
of gloves okay yeah all right dude I
already resigned dude
if that's not true if that's false Nick
should resign I'm out of here dude I
have of us have resigned now real life
re-elect Nick is what I say oh [ __ ] he
said rubber gloves yeah I said rubber
gloves man I said it from the beginning
third term thank you
how do you turn down the fire grid the
power
I think I think they don't want to say
how they did it because it's a huge
vulnerability that's one because I just
pictured them going to like the main
chord that powers the whole [ __ ] City
and going
yeah and cutting it that could be a
picture of them I'm like it's one in the
office and pressing like the off switch
I mean and if you still gotta drive to
the liquor store that they wanted to Rob
ordinary latex gloves
can be insulated thank you but they do
not protect from electric shock that's
not true though it was not a disgrace
that's stupid that's not true I was
thinking the rubber gloves
so it's your Source dude
no the thick electricity
you got to be a premium user by the way
of course the density of the gloves is
not enough and too thin they still may
be electrified I can't believe you
[ __ ] pay for quora dude people just
died because they watched this video and
they listen to you Nick will you please
respond
you can't use latex gloves for
electrical stuff it needs to be the
thick rubber ones
[Music]
we're just stuck in a Time Loop what if
I triple it up what I think you'd be
fine if it's the thick rubber plates
three gloves
no you did double condom no Joe did why
would you ever do why did you do double
cards wait you've actually worn two I'm
gonna try that I know I didn't he tells
me you're not even gonna feel anything
anymore
you already don't feel anything now
you're not gonna put anything there's
like a sermon yeah yeah so bars
tournament what Bart's trying to say is
don't wear condoms out there right yeah
yes
I just bought one and said like ultra
thin for sensitive I'll see if it's true
hey you still wear condoms yeah yeah Dan
don't be all judgedy resigns
you're trying to make kids though huh
nah
just pull out dude that's not fun no no
oh my g over there dude I pull in you
leave it in what I like that too because
at when I go you know what
this is dangerous and then I put on a
condom and then I bust inside okay
that's the ritual every time you have
sex you have to say this is dangerous or
sometimes I go push it to them this is
dangerous
it's a 925 Market where you say this is
dangerous you know what's crazy though
like when I talk to some of my single
friends it is like it is crazy to see
how many of those dudes like have sex
with random chicks with no condoms I
know how many of them just leave it in
bro they are a lot of winners hey
comments oh I actually did that a couple
times while the women already disclosing
that they're on birth control
why did you do that were you I was just
excited yeah
I just said laugh afterwards yeah it is
pretty sick well it was like a head [ __ ]
too because like I had known her for a
while and I was like whoa [ __ ] Nikki
limo it's kind of crazy it's been a
while that is that is way cooler yeah
it's cool right it's cooler because you
think you see them in this one light and
then suddenly it's like a new chapter
and you see their [ __ ] in your face
I don't want to tell you because it's
pretty personal
oh just turn off the cameras but leave
it alive
yeah no I was talking about busting and
all this [ __ ] I'm not gonna say that no
I don't remember what happened after I
just remember her being like Oh yeah you
came that hard to remember you just oh
for sure well luckily we brought in your
son come over here George
towards George Green Arizona
[Music]
foreign
[Music]